we all do yeah I don't get it though
like some guy I was I don't know about
my [ __ ] bro oh yeah
launches over my go sit by the window in
zero we're gonna find the kid
oops you interrupted me yeah now the
danger in that is you don't get a jewel
right well the danger in you
interrupting me is if you don't let
Daddy drop a jewel right now we all like
just daddy yeah yeah people are dying
I'm gonna [ __ ] give you some hot hot
heat if I'm gonna give you a [ __ ]
lasagna of a conversation because the
hollows on you Oh boomer apologize no
I'm not apologizing for Schumer as I
forget it now let me [ __ ] remember
what it is and everyone be silent until
I [ __ ] remember what it is
keep telling quiet no I can't remember
no [ __ ] dude those hot lasagnas gone
dude what are you gonna happen
anything could [ __ ] have it you can
have I could get up and plant my left
foot in on the bridge of your nose and
not hang into that oh and not that ugly
a stupid [ __ ] medieval grandfather
clock that you have for some reason oh
why do you have that you don't come into
my studio and start threatening physical
stuff because I'll tell you something
right now yeah well right now yeah right
now right
okay you come at me yeah yeah yeah
what's gonna happen I don't know what's
gonna happen but I do know one thing for
sure right you know for sure that I'm
gonna I'm gonna me don't fall asleep I
don't do that mmm that's very
disrespectful wait look at this because
if you do you know what that is what
that's me in deep REM sleep dreaming of
you trying to come out not dreaming of a
you wait hold on this is what I look
like
hold on when I'm asleep and I'm dream
Sean asked you out here I'm gonna show
it to you again
ready this is how I have severe sleep
apnea already
then this is me not breathing for a
minute and a half and then here's the
part where I dream are you ready and
then it goes getting purple no oxygen
definitely having a stroke watch the
world record for Will Sasso two minutes
18 seconds no oxygen and then more
dreaming you get the picture oh my god
so oh my god what would happen if I came
at you I don't know what would happen
will i but if you come at me
I know one thing 100% for sure right
you'll [ __ ] your pain no you'll [ __ ]
your pillow no I want you insulting son
of a [ __ ] if you come at me
Wow piece you up I mean that what you
see up is that some prank okay okay
okay give up yeah finish I mean you give
me a mich meat now pie I don't mean me
no I'll meet you halfway
yeah I'll meet you halfway yeah so
that's all I can guarantee that I'll
meet ya so I enjoy great works of art
you know Sistine Chapel of course
beautiful I've heard the Great Wall I
know what the Great Wall isn't a piece
of artwork but it is a a man-made
achievement yeah be able to keep it that
we goes out yes
Orion come I love going to museums and I
love seeing beautiful even albums like
album like sergeant Pepper's lion
beetles yeah yeah and you know over the
years I haven't really seen great art
until this weekend and I bought tickets
to see a movie called choker
and I saw an actor and that movie do the
best back acting world Wow now it just
says I loo finish careful everyone walk
I can you okay this is the screen okay
this is the screen right here okay yeah
and when you can act only having this
image of your face in a screen probably
also just think of this still in a split
second so this is this is only on the
screen for a split second Bobby said
this what you see right right this way
okay Bobby right well that's the end of
my right and this and the acting in this
second I stood up no in the theater now
you didn't say that no you know what I
said I'll be honest with you I stood up
I said loser look I turned it everyone
in the field item I don't know him Bobby
in fact I told you this earlier when he
was in the bathroom right
my girlfriend's knees from the
Philippines right was in the theater
she's my [ __ ] okay yeah when you we
heard your voice yeah on kalila goes hey
did the knees Bobby no that's just
friend ain't no a Sudanese super shitty
for you it's a big movie I didn't know
that that uh Santino and Cowan had like
a friendly beef mmm-hmm it's hilarious
it's not friendly anymore apparently not
you know it we were on stage at our show
the other day at the store in the main
room yes auntie you know Santino is a
passionate fiery guy the most fun
someone who just goes so how do you
really feel about kaolin he says that
the Santino and its Santino just sort of
ripping like what bro he's like going in
he's like his materials days look like I
let me take the microphone away I go
this is family business
this backspace for two people here
lighten them up I feel like you're that
way with everybody except me really
except for you yeah but I but I do that
with Kalin because I just his little
cocky attitude he's got to way too much
attitude when he comes in the green room
he's got way too much attitude he
prances around like he owns the place I
don't like it even as money a lot like
the LIA Flash's money yeah but it's
different because it's fun yeah Kalin
does it and it makes me so [ __ ] mad
dude I'm gonna choke him out and kill
him as little skinny neck I'm back to
thinking this is real the things he was
saying weren't like it's personal oh
yeah who's really it was like there's a
lot out there but certain shoes like
especially dunks dunks are like right
now done sb dunks are like the hot what
are dunks did you see the shoes times
why do you act like this why do you ruin
every conversation oh you just ruin
every girl why you're like my daddy cool
the second ones in the Valentine sense
those are dope Papa just got those
that's cool I swear you're so annoying
why I'm sure dope those are sick by the
way though I got I you know hook you up
with my got your and uh I'll pass I
don't that's in San Antonio but boy Jake
does custom shoes for LeBron Beckham
everybody that's brought me custom
custom supreme ones low tops show him
those chin Brian go get us something
[ __ ] no I want to be part of this oh
I lost some friends all this kicks you
know what I hate the most is like this
would be such a great conversation yeah
you're ruining why I'm not doing
anything else you're ruining the library
old I'm listening you're being very old
no I'm not I'm saying it's like fresh
and dodo those are such a sick so he
makes them for Nike he make he gets the
all the the all the
the materials are from where Nike gets
theirs oh really oh and just refurbished
is the whole thing does its own style oh
this is so good I'm really like a really
detailed how do they get that dope that
dope you're annoying Wow Wow get back on
set bro I'm literally just sitting here
as an actor as a working actor then time
will show you how much line again how
long does it take you to remember your
three lines in that show no first of all
like three look that's ashy anything the
sayings I'm the star and also I have a
photographic memory
yeah and no one believed that that's why
without completely July it
I remember the internet shut down who's
ever seen the show but funny guy when he
did that I laughed my [ __ ] show it
was [ __ ] interrupt is my show all right
yeah it's called floods do you must have
to go sleep I love you guys cuz I love
you guys man we know what I'll do I love
you guys I don't think that's it I love
to you and you know it's [ __ ]
distracted by his accent no not really
look like Tom Hardy I get that a lot you
know I think it's a compliment you
couldn't be bigger
he's 140 naturally well we're not well
that we're not you didn't say you're the
same size as di Hardy I don't know your
pal I get all the time you're probably
Tom Hardy sighs who would you say I'm a
little bigger taller I'm definitely
stronger hold on you went mmm
don't get what oh don't do that go ahead
no go hmm I say that cuz I did a movie
with him now
with Tom what with Tom Hardy oh you did
yeah with which one Tom Hardy which
movie a movie called warrior oh yeah
hell of an actor though yo yeah is that
the high that's the fighter one yes
ladies the brothers yes yeah thought of
no desire so warrior you'd like I don't
like fight move has nothing to with
fighting you'd love it oh it's a story
brothers
who have to fight phenomenal yeah you
were great in that you played what is
accountant feel like you're being okay
so I'm gonna ask you I played you like a
city yes he was Jack see that Bryan
Callen you played basically the Joe
Rogan okay the Joe Rogan role
oh you did I did did you beat yeah so
that was he's a lot where I keep doing
it quietly and you're being in having a
Socratic thing you're you're asking
questions but I think you know the
answer so thank you for saying that I
Socrates I didn't I didn't give you a
but I was a handsome son of a [ __ ] take
a look at me let's zoom in on that
picture I'm listen you need to fill out
the 401k no this is gonna be a lot of
money and you want to put it away
no and no that's not use it when you're
60 because it'll grow those weren't the
[ __ ] Lions you know your shoot was
tailored I look well yes askew actually
it's a tighter suit demands that ankle
right cuz now are you it looks like
you're you're in a fight in that scene
well my natural I have a martial
presence my natural tilt marshal my chin
down so if you swing at me
you're gonna catch forehead mo and joel
edgerton xin that too huh yeah i'm not
gonna catch forehead he's a monster
and a good writer and a director yeah
though both guys are those are two
mountains of acting yeah and and then
you got you in there and that's just
great for you trying to track no I knew
what you're saying that I'm doing it I
don't really know you do realize it but
I really don't know coach Joe wait you
know what that's my camera which one's
my that was the only way if you had
worked on in your face cuz you look
tight no no it's that's asian so like
what do you have Asian genes yeah you
don't get that many lines across the
forehead right so yours is like like a
tree like when you cut a tree you count
I say to the tree so [ __ ] happen why is
it agree there's like seven rings like
your piece of sorry inning every
ring is 10 years show yeah so that's
like I say it's more like a packet of
Bakker don't have a pack of bacon yeah
yeah say that about my face man I'm
wearing makeup so the the 11th okay so
you know when you cut a tree yes and you
see the Rings I hate this plant account
you can't count how old the tree is and
buy the Rings I know you says you like
when you like like raise your eyebrows
no just raise your eyebrows no that's a
black surprise real quick like look up
look up Wow yeah
each line is like seven years no it's
not how did you can count 10 no don't
what is 7 times 6 I'm bad at math it's
like 79 or 4240 there's the other thing
so then that's wrong yeah yeah that's
wrong it wants peace do it again one
more time fine I'm gonna do it again but
don't I won't no you know me I'm not
shitty come on oh you forgot the line in
the middle of his eyebrows hey so 7
times 8 is 56 right your your head is
like dog ears each line is like 7 years
can't say my face is a tree and like dog
years you can't say these are stand-up
comics Brian we know we know you're here
and you know I'm a stand-up comic you
can't you know come on try to follow me
hey hey Jason Jason don't be cocky
honest in this car they call me the
machine gun weena don't call you that
let me see [ __ ] never heard that never
heard the people could you talk too fast
and we can't understand your bits that's
how what it is Oh guys you know what
this is prior 1,000 mod cast
yeah hello yes a million dollars call me
when you're serious you're not that you
didn't answer it hey you don't know you
didn't say that right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[ __ ] business